what's up everybody I'm Jessie T Usher
and I play a train I'm Anthony star I
play Jack Wade and I play Huey mm-hmm my
name is chase Crawford I played the deep
I'm Karen fuku car and I play the female
hi I'm Karl Urban and I played Billy
butcher Laz Alonso
I played Mother's Milk Erin Moriarty I
placed our lives don't make a bond
playing friendship
I'm gonna send regular Wow
[Music]
what did you open a bake sale a tough
exterior British softie as well scary
character so I hope I'm not that in real
life
the greatest thing ever the 181st is
watching you when they say cut and then
you reverting back to the nicest
sweetest person yeah you are
you're like rhythm people's heads off
and then you're like it's yeah it's the
best
yeah kara so soon she's always Canadian
yeah well no actually no no yeah one of
me you're really honest and butcher you
never know what he's telling the truth
or when he's lying means fool
[Music]
okay you know what yeah you go that's
what I've seen a mother Karen I think
Karen and Zeile I go with Jason yeah he
takes pride in yeah
are we done yet this is lunch yet come
on guys he's not here Nathan
oh yeah yeah
hey Matt me is literally a puppy he's a
wind-up toy and every now then miss a
beat Nokomis a she's like you can see
the glaze it does that we're empowered
them that's controlled narcolepsy which
is there I want that like sleep now for
weak tiny stuff right yeah
nothing stuff I didn't get one but I do
ask a lot jack to dance cause it loves
it and white Tamara practices his
English by imitating all of us yeah
mr. Jack's alright so Jack's come up see
oh hey buddy I'm just gonna do one of
chase that I haven't done from here yeah
I don't know
when I went golfing dude I did
[Music]